payet jean françois 58 ans premier
adjoint à la mairie de saint-louis
délégué à la sécurité enfin louis et au
département délégué route
je suis élu du canton 16 celui de la
rivière si la hausse est de l'antre 2
moi je suis j'ai grandi au marque
gvt scolarisés à saint louis et je vis
actuellement à la rivière donc un pure
jalousie
oui mais les actions prioritaires
nos deux gros chantiers qui nous
tiennent à coeur jean saint louis il
faut qu'on l'appuie justement ces
dossiers c'est celui du ouaki et celui
des 3 ravines et comme je suis déléguée
aux routes je me pensais aussi à un fait
rare à faire ces travaux
dans le département on fait déjà
beaucoup de choses mais je pense que au
niveau social le département et chef de
file des actions sociales donc il faudra
travailler là dessus en sachant que nous
ici sur saint louis on est incité comme
une des communes les plus pauvres donc
absolument il faudra travailler vraiment
sur le social